hey um i want to kind of go through a
sampling of the nutty stuff that
happened over this weekend with
republicans none of these clips that i'm
going to play for you
is sort of worthy of its own story but
sometimes it's just stunning how much
absurdity the american right gets into
over a 48-hour weekend that i want to
just give you like a little bit of a
tour through the bonkers um uh
universe of the american right so let's
just look at a couple of things real
quick melania trump was given an award
by the log cabin republicans called the
spirit of lincoln award
and melania gave a speech with a
teleprompter of course even though trump
and the right hates teleprompters when
obama uses them um and it's just all
very weird i amplified legislation and
created awareness campaigns that
elevated important issues such as foster
care sickle cell disease
social emotional learning techniques
and neonatal absences
so just
everything is
so weird it's hard to even know what the
hell is going on with these strange
awards that they hand each other so that
was melania roger stone former guest on
this show
convicted
pardoned okay you know roger stone roger
stone appeared on alex jones's infowars
and said infowars is what you can trust
for the truth
for wars is a beacon of freedom that's
why infowars can always be counted on
for the truth you can always go to
infowars.com and find out what is really
going on yeah now if you're curious
about roger stone check out the time i
interviewed him the big kind of weird
story with that was
up until about 30 seconds before the
interview you could hear him in the
background trying to get out of the
interview and then he sat down uh and
did the interview just an odd guy and
now this connection between i mean this
guy was a trump a really a trump in as
close to a friend as trump ever had
now just openly saying infowars is the
source that you have to trust um senator
josh hawley one of the insiders of the
january 6th insurrection did a very
strange sit-down interview with axios
and he went on a rant about the left
attacking manhood and he criticized
video games and porn just strange take a
look what's a man to you paint a picture
what's a man well a man is a father a
man as a husband a man of somebody who
takes responsibility as conservatives
we've got to call men back to
responsibility we've got to say that
spending your time not working and we
have more and more men who are not
working spending your time on video
games spending your time watching porn
online while doing nothing is not good
for you your family or this country so a
viewer's watching in this and they're
thinking really what the liberals are
doing are going to push me to watch
pornhub more or play donkey kong more do
you mean that little well what i mean
literally is that i think the liberal
attack the left-wing attack on manhood
says to men you're part of the problem
it says that your your masculinity is
inherently problematic it's inherently
oppressive what a weird interview and
continued right wing obsession
with these caricatures
of what i guess they see as the alpha
male
and the beta male
and
a very unusual rant i guess i'm
struggling to even find the words for it
for a sitting senator to go on but video
games and porn that's
beta in the mind i guess of what josh
hawley sees as manhood
many anti-mask and anti-vax protests
continuing over the weekend not just in
the united states but in other countries
as we will soon see here's one from the
u.s here is a picture
of just one woman
holding a sign that says masks are child
abuse which they're not
masks are physical
and psychological abuse but
psychological is misspelled
on this woman's mask so that's something
um in a completely i i know i've i used
this term last week
in another one of these kafka-esque
moments
here is cancun cruz republican senator
ted cruz
uh attacking john kerry for flying to
the climate conference last week on a
private jet and he points out
none of us have private jets and then
someone says actually uh ted
rob portman
does have a private jet um take a look
at this
john kerry has a private jet
that has flown dozens of times this past
year all around the country
i don't know about you but i don't have
a private jet i don't believe any of the
people on this stage have their own
private jet portman
[Laughter]
one of the issues with making this
personal is you might have someone up on
the stage where the personal makes you
look like a hypocrite and of course the
bigger issue is how much should we be
talking about private jet use in
thinking about climate and as i talked
about last week
the people that have the private jets
are going to keep having the private
jets let's get them off of fossil fuels
and into renewables that would be my
preference and of course the vast
majority of carbon emissions are not
coming from aviation at all never mind
from private jets i mentioned it last
week and then here's an australian
anti-mask anti-vaxx guy who's listing
all of the things he doesn't do
and hilariously he says he doesn't
satanize his hands instead of sanitize
it's satanized this is wild i'm 60 years
old i don't socially distance i never
wore a mask during the whole lockdown i
always go to the supermarket as much as
i like
i don't sterilize my hands or satanize
them i just live normally and naturally
just like i've always done of course
from time to time like anybody else i
might get ill and if i do i go to bed i
have some honey and lemon tea and i
sweat it out and then i recover this is
the way everyone should live
and uh i'm not against medicine but i
think medicine has taken too far we have
too much trust yes the satanization of
hands that's really something else so a
wild weekend in right wing la la land
it's more scary than funny you know
individually we might look at a clip and
we might say oh that actually is pretty
funny and we would be right to say it's
funny but the big picture is there is an
entire movement not just in the united
states but globally to some degree we've
seen it in europe we see it in australia
etc certainly here in the u.s an entire
movement based on not just ignorance but
pride
in ignorance pride in non-thinking pride
in rejecting empiricism and science and
that's a really really bad thing